hello and welcome back so in our last
lesson we added this lovely view
leaderboards controller that doesn't
show anything because we have no leader
boards so let's think about adding some
now we have three difficulty levels in
our game easy medium and hard probably
make sense for each one to have its own
leaderboard so let's go ahead and do
that I'm going to pop over to Chrome
here and shrink this a bit and I'm going
to go to play google com / app / publish
the developer console and check out our
game services and let's go into guess my
number so we can go into leaderboards
and the process here is fairly similar
to adding achievements we fill out all
the various information that we need in
a form and then the system generates a
unique ID for us that we can use later
to refer to this leaderboard so let's do
that I'm going to click on add
leaderboard and for this one our name is
going to be easy and this will be the
leader board for an easy difficulty
level we have some options for score
formatting it can be numeric which would
be like an integer or a floating-point
we also have options for currency and
time and maybe if we wanted to do a
fastest time to guess the answer type of
leader board we can use time for that we
have an icon this is optional I do
recommend using icons if you want to
create say actual games that you want
people to download and by the reason is
that in the play games standalone
application your leaderboard icons do
show up fairly prominently someone looks
at your game one of the three screens
that they're going to see about your
game are going to be your leader boards
and in those cases it's nice to have
leaderboard icons that you know look
interesting in our case we're going to
stick with the default leaderboard icon
as provided by Play game services which
is like a little crown thing ordering
here we can choose whether larger is
better or smaller is better in this case
our leaderboard is going to be based on
the number of guesses so how many
guesses did it take to get the mat
number so in this case smaller is better
i do want to take a moment to add this
is my favorite feature of this developer
console rather than like having
ascending or descending and then you
have to stop and think what was that
actually mean like smaller is better so
much clearer love it anyway then we have
limits and these are basically the upper
and lower bounds of any score that's
gets submitted to this leaderboard so i
suppose we want to say that we don't
want to allow scores lower than one make
sense you can't actually make a guess
in0 guesses and maybe for the small
leaderboard we want to say you know what
let's not allow scores greater than 100
you know in theory someone could make
the same wrong guess over and over and
over and over again and I don't know
maybe our players are going to have some
fun perverse hey let's see who can get
the worst score in our guests our number
game contest maybe that's something you
want to encourage your players to do but
in my case I'm going to say no let's not
encourage that behavior we're just going
to cap our lower bounds or I guess their
upper bounds here at 100 and list order
means that if you were to view your
leader boards where would disappear on
the list and we'll have it appear first
so there we go this is done I'm going to
hit save and add another leader board
will create another one for medium this
should be pretty easy smaller's better
and let's allow scores of one and a
thousand save and add another
leaderboard and hard smaller's better
and one in 10,000 let's save and we're
done look at that we've got three
leaderboards we have unique IDs
associated with each one of them and
they should be ready to publish we've
actually done everything we need to do
to get a leaderboard into our game so
let's go back to our application try it
out if I were to hit leaderboards right
now I'd probably yeah I'd get the cached
version so one quick way to fix this
would be to sign out and sign back in or
you could just you know stop and run our
application again and now it'll kind of
force our game to go out and grab the
latest data so now when i click
leaderboards I now have
reentry's easy medium and hard now if I
were to click on this easy one I'm taken
to my individual leaderboard where I can
see entries for public submissions to
this leaderboard and anybody for my
circles that has submitted a score to
this leaderboard in this case this is a
brand new leader board nobody submitted
anything so all these entries are blank
that's kind of too bad and kind of
boring but that's okay because in the
next lesson we'll start submitting
scores to these leaderboards so stay
tuned and I'll see you soon
haha